[Musica]
ciao ragazzi cerchiamo scuola nessuno a
scuola se volete milan resa volo che
cosa ci facciamo qua a scuola il nostro
libro storie paurose è subito rubato
giornata bakhita un insegnante ma loro
mi insegnante normale un insegnante
fauro sapete chi è fatto presto dobbiamo
cercarlo subito nella classic ore
di volo
e se non lo vedo ancora lasciato un mi
piace mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace
qui sotto vediamo cosa c'è scritto in
questo palermo 6 intervenuto e baciato e
pali che ci ha messo le sottrazioni di
quaderni le addizioni e le
moltiplicazioni le divisioni tutto
quanto dobbiamo quindi trovare i tetti
potermi nel risolvere in tutte le
quotazioni è forse riusciremo a
riappropriarsi del nostro libro
dai presto
344 ok abbiamo risolto dalle nostre
prime operazioni che dobbiamo trovarne
altre sei vediamoci
[Musica]
c'è stato chi è stato sempre il momento
di fare questa inter
risolviamo l'operazione 15 diviso tra il
105 105
abbiamo risolto anche la seconda
operazione bloccata solo dal naso ok ma
che ora sta andando tutto benissimo ma
non è vero ancora non si è fatto vedere
balti
[Musica]
hai dei soci caravati è passato
sacerdote fu ripreso ma speri tra poco
tornerò in quella plast a prendere il
righello qua dentro
[Applauso]
quando questi ceduto vennero scudi
ascolti
ci sta cercando quali una grande
dobbiamo aspettare che calzi nasconditi
scappiamo da questa classe prima che
torni quasi
non c'è questo
non ha ancora ritrovato ben righello
forse è meglio se glielo portiamo morini
si così magari non staremo simpatici e
magari non ci inseguirà viene
visto che sappiamo dove proviamo
portarlo
e così calmo ma come la mettiamo con
video e lo tiriamo in testa così magari
ci ridarà il libro storie paurose
[Musica]
bas che passa
ci è mancato poco
non ci ho trovato neanche qua oppure ci
sta evitando non vuole che ritroviamo il
libro storie forum troviamo gli altri
poteri e risolviamo niente cooper azioni
o personalità boldi mio preso ma vitale
non ha preso vita le altre delle domande
vita
ma voi avete lasciato un mi piace furono
20 ancora lasciato un mi piace da sempre
lega ma se dobbiamo riprendere il libro
e non sono tutto non trovare boldi
qui c'è un problema però ho dimenticato
ben battuto
intascato dell'interno una classe
prendere un gessetto perché li possiamo
offrire ma giusto
su dieci
il libro il tenerlo ragione dice 10 meno
2 è una sottrazione 8 ho scritto questo
fragile
speriamo che vada bene ma si sa che
sarebbe già arrivato balbi
di cisco
come
la ricerca
correzione
pazzini
[Musica]
[Applauso]
facciamo ma se n'è accorto mato grosso
piatto
forse siamo al sicuro ma presto dobbiamo
completare l'altra forma l'altra
operazione dirci quante volte vi abbiamo
completato credo 55 se ne mancano solo
due si cercano
presto questo punto uno stato fatto così
battista perché abbiamo finì 2 2 abbiamo
controllato quella casa e siamo a 4
ma la cia scrittori e non c'è scritto
niente come facciamo risolvere le
operazioni adesso possiamo scrivere una
risposta a qualsiasi visto che non c'è
scritto niente no è meglio non rischiare
potrebbe arrabbiarsi molto bello è bello
è ragione possiamo andare di là alla
luce giocare riusciamo a vedere cosa c'è
scritto siamo già presto non c'è scritto
niente su come facciamo
l'immagine
completa molto poco sono sicura che un
tranello è un qualche trucchetto di base
dobbiamo scoprire come trovare
l'operazione e come possiamo fare
possiamo passare un sestetto sopra
non si vede molto neanche così
cosa
mission impossible iii
passa la chiave apre
con una mission impossible e carattere
a gustavo aspettava in quanti pani avete
abbiamo un ciclo di lezioni non c'era un
accordo la nuvoletta questa si può
aprire no è una chiave diversa perché
laggiù non siamo andati avanti un organo
scoprire la sia successo
anno era uno specchio mi sono visto che
questo
mi stai precisione su un quadernino
partiamo
scusa
facciamo bene dove la penna
[Musica]
per 84 per 8 32 32 ok ora portiamo
questo poterli noi cerchiamo di aprire
qualcosa con questa chiave
quindi forse bordi non è classica attivo
cioè vuole solo che finiamo il web di
essi però perché ci insegue con un
righello eh vabbè andiamo a cerreto
guidi ormai
divenuto leader forse è meglio se ci
dividiamo così possiamo controllare
meglio tutta al tutto il perimetro della
scuola ok o me ne vado
tutti sarà
tutto solari cassetto da prete romagna
qui non c'è niente vita rita è trovato
qualcosa
sì che questo campetto è chiuso è stato
chiuso a chiave quindi forse questa
chiave la prima si svegliano probabile
regolatore
si pronuncerà giusta
cosa c'è all'interno
una pila non ce la facciamo niente di
una pila possiamo attenderle nun ci
aspetta al buio magari in si vede meglio
non funziona nemmeno funzioni
perché questa pila perché non ho
capito forse dobbiamo illuminare un
qualche messaggio segreto
scrive sia qualcosa di scritto nel
quaderno del quaderno rosso in cui non
c'era scritto niente di
meno
qualche messaggio nel segreto nascosto
8x3
uguale
vero però come vero ma che cosa
significa 8x3 uguale zero ma non parte
8x3 è una trappola e un tranello
sicuramente
che cosa continui possiamo vedere se
venezia quando invece formulato
qual è il primo quaderno che abbiamo
preso questo
viviamo
c'è scritto qualcosa se c'è scritto se
vuoi
superare
no se vuoi sapere dove ho nascosto
storie paurose
leggi tutti gli indizi
[Musica]
cosa abbiamo qui invece qua abbiamo una
b qua
una
e qui una
mld a
m su quello che c'è scritto bia
che lettera non lo trovo poi lo vedete
che c è una ci
aspetta vediamo di comporre la parola
abili a via
ccm bach
bamba
dobbiamo dare in banca
siamo in una scuola perché dovremmo
andare in barca sicuramente le sponde
nell'ultimo quadernino forse se
ritroviamo questa operazione di tutto
per tre uguale zero ma che cosa vuol
dire forse tu mi 10 forse una banca
[Applauso]
che gli fosse un parco banco con
troviamo tutti i marchi
decine e decine di palloni in questa
scuola
[Musica]
perché molto ma 349
[Applauso]
[Musica]
se n'è andato un dato ha visto che hai
fatto i compiti e le code euro medi per
nulla dovuto lì
c'è una luce accesa da giu prima era
spenta la luce in quella classe forse
vuol dire che la un libro non diamo
subito conto che andiamo a controllare
sia da
dice che ci abbattino attento non mi
sembra di sentire alcune nuove che va al
di là dentro
facciamo vedere
per me
chi è
detto permesso che ne so io sono queste
le prime chi era privo di aprire
preso controlli molto ogni bar così
perché adesso pozzo nero banco quindi
dobbiamo controllare sotto ogni banco se
c'è il libro
io ho trovato tutta la stato in francia
no non c'è niente sotto questi bambini
22 niente neanche a cui guarda
questo con software voto
sì allora libro
abbiamo ritrovato il nostro libretto
lavoro tra scuola di vita
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e voi l'avete preso è ora disponibile in
ogni libro è anche online se non ce
l'avete non potete non aver rotto
potrebbe essere bellissime che vi
lasceranno col piatto non deve avere una
fine non riuscirete a smettere di legge
è ora che abbiamo recuperato il nostro
libro possiamo scappare passivo
scappiamo via da tanti
ci sono sintomo di ciao
[Musica]